[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a esta edición especial
de los observadores dedicada a la
situación en myanmar dos años después
del golpe de estado que devolvió al
poder al ejército y desencadenó un
conflicto armado con los grupos de la
oposición
en miamar el conflicto desencadenado por
el golpe de estado a desatado fuertes
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas de
defensa del pueblo y las milicias
aliadas contra el gobierno militar
Un gobierno militar que gobierna el país
con puño de hierro los disidentes son
reprimidos los activistas prodemocracias
son ejecutados y han sido también
documentados asesinatos masivos de
civiles
según los activistas las autoridades
también han incendiado pueblos enteros
[Música]
una de las armas empleadas en esta
guerra son justamente los incendios la
ong mian Mark witness que Investiga los
abusos contra los derechos humanos desde
el golpe de estado estima que diciembre
de 2022 fue un mes récord en cuanto al
número de incendios uno de sus
investigadores birmanos nos cuenta lo
que descubrió y da su testimonio
guardando el anonimato por motivos de
seguridad
la junta militar tiene varias maneras de
intentar suprimir los recursos con los
que cuenta la oposición
es decir las PDF que son las fuerzas de
defensa del pueblo y las eao las
organizaciones étnicas armadas
no solo las combaten sino que también
destruyen las ciudades los pueblos y las
comunidades que respaldan a las PDF y
las eau
la junta militar ha estado quemando
decenas de viviendas de civiles cada mes
desde al menos finales de 2021
y las cifras siguen aumentando la junta
militar quiere sembrar el miedo en la
población
de que sus refugio y sus recursos no
estarán seguros si se unen a la
oposición una de las estrategias de la
junta es crear el caos en la sociedad
según el último informe de la ong al
menos 1,2 millones de personas han sido
desplazadas desde el golpe de estado
Los Defensores de los Derechos Humanos
calculan al menos 2,700 muertos
uno de los objetivos de Mean Mark
witness es reunir pruebas y permitir que
las víctimas obtengan justicia
recolectamos documentamos y almacenamos
analizamos y verificamos casos de las
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
incluidos los incendios
para esto examinamos contenidos de
código abierto en internet como
publicaciones públicas en redes sociales
y artículos en páginas web de noticias
también utilizamos herramientas de
acceso público como firmes
una herramienta en línea de la Nasa que
muestra datos sobre incendios activos
casi en tiempo real son violaciones muy
graves de los Derechos Humanos
[Música]
importa cual sea el lugar el momento el
autor o la víctima esos actos deben
documentarse verificarse y denunciarse
adecuadamente para contribuir a la
defensa de los Derechos Humanos
para los ex dirigentes Pro democracia de
myanmar estos incendios son crímenes de
guerra por su parte un grupo de
observadores independientes también ha
reunido pruebas para las Naciones Unidas
de lo que consideran son crímenes contra
la humanidad cometidos por el gobierno
militar este grupo planea presentarlas
ante la Corte Penal Internacional
[Música]
estos hombres mujeres y niños son
refugiados rojinya pasaron días a la
deriva en el mar en un barco cuyo motor
se averió muchos de los pasajeros
murieron los rojin ya son
predominantemente musulmanes y son
perseguidos en su país de origen miamar
casi un millón de ellos han huido al
vecino bangladesh en los últimos años
pero muchos ya no soportan seguir
viviendo en los campamentos de
refugiados desde finales de noviembre
varios barcos han salido del puerto de
Cox bazar con la esperanza de llegar
hasta Malasia y se han encontrado con
condiciones similares Ninguno de los
países vecinos los quiere acoger nuestro
observador es un refugiado rojinya que
nació y creció en este campamento y nos
cuenta su testimonio para proteger su
seguridad desea permanecer en el
anonimato todos los barcos tienen
problemas porque son barcos viejos el
motor de una de las embarcaciones se
averió quedaron varados en el mar sin
comida ni agua Los Traficantes de
personas llevan comida para 100 personas
50 personas o 200 personas pero en los
barcos hay 400 personas
es un pequeño barco de Vela
después de más de un mes a la deriva los
sobrevivientes de la embarcación cuyo
motor estaba averiado Fueron rescatados
por Pescadores indonesios según la ong
project que monitorea este tipo de
embarcaciones otro grupo había sido
rescatado unos días antes otros barcos
quedaron a la deriva durante varias
semanas con diferentes desenlaces uno
por ejemplo fue asistido por la armada
de shidi lanka mientras que los
pasajeros de un barco rescatado por la
armada de myanmar en diciembre pasado
fueron encarcelados otro barco
desapareció después de haber enviado una
señal de
Sosa en los campamentos de los ya no
tienen instalaciones sanitarias agua ni
no hay libertad de circulación no hay
agua potable en caso de emergencia no
pueden salir del campamento son
hostigados por las autoridades del campo
y por los habitantes de la comunidad de
acogida es una prisión al aire libre no
estamos seguros en mi al mar ni en
bangladesh
Entonces si vamos a morir a Malasia No
pasa nada
en enero la ong
denunció abusos cometidos por la policía
en el campamento de Cox Bazar
insiste en que urge llegar a un acuerdo
entre Tailandia Indonesia y Malasia para
garantizar que las personas a bordo de
estas embarcaciones sean asistidas
llegamos al final de este programa
especial de los observadores dedicado a
la situación de miamar dos años después
del golpe militar recuerde que usted
puede comunicarse con la producción del
programa nuestros contactos aparecen en
sus pantallas nos vemos en una próxima
oportunidad Hasta pronto